la suma de 4 enteros impares
consecutivos es igual a 136 cuáles son
esos 4 enteros antes de que empecemos a
resolver esto vamos a pensar en lo que
significa enteros impares consecutivos a
qué se refiere 4 enteros impares
consecutivos para entender esto podemos
empezar con 3 digamos que tenemos este 3
y el siguiente entero impar sería 5 el
siguiente es 7 y el número impar que
sigue después de este es 9
estos son enteros impares consecutivos y
vamos a ver otro ejemplo si empezamos
con el 11 el siguiente entero impares 13
el siguiente es 15 y el que sigue es 17
un ejemplo de enteros impares no
consecutivos sería digamos 3 seguido por
el 7 estos no son consecutivos el
siguiente entero en par después del 3 es
el 5 17 estos son ejemplos entre los
impares consecutivos y este es un
ejemplo de enteros impares no
consecutivos
después de ver esto vamos a resolver
esta pregunta y los invito a qué pausa
en el vídeo y traten de resolverla por
ustedes mismos antes de que yo lo hagan
como pueden imaginar vamos a usar un
poco de álgebra así que digamos que x es
el entero más pequeño de los cuatro
enteros impares sea x el más pequeño de
los cuatro enteros y vamos a expresar
los otros tres en términos de x así que
podemos usar estos ejemplos que tenemos
aquí si este es x como expresaríamos el
siguiente en términos de x
bueno pues éste sería x + 2 el siguiente
entero impar es igual a la anterior más
2 lo que estamos haciendo es saltar el
siguiente número que es un número par si
tenemos un número impar el que sigue es
un número par así que para asaltarlo
debemos sumar 2 y si sumamos otros dos
tenemos x + 4 y si sumamos otros 2 a eso
tendremos x + 6 y vemos eso nuevamente
en este ejemplo si este número este x
éste es x + 2 este otro es x + 4 y este
es x + 6 en general si x es el más
pequeño de los 4
podemos definir los otros tres como x +
2 x 4 x 6 y podemos sumarlos a igualar
los a 136 así que el primero el más
pequeño es x el siguiente es x + 2 el
que sigue es x + 4 y el que sigue
después de este es x + 6 y aquí tenemos
la suma de los cuatro enteros impares
consecutivos y nos dicen que la suma de
estos cuatro es igual a 136 así que lo
igualamos a 136 y lo que podemos hacer
literalmente es despejar x y tenemos
solamente una incógnita vamos a sumar
las x que tenemos aquí una x 2 x 3 x 4x
y podemos reescribirlo como 4x y luego
tenemos dos más 4 que es igual a 6 + 6
nos da 12 y entonces tenemos 4x + 12 es
igual a 136
ahora vamos a despejar x y dejar este
término de un lado de la ecuación y
quitar este 12 y para deshacernos de
este 12 tenemos que restar 12 de este
lado de la ecuación y no podemos hacer
esto solo del lado izquierdo de la
ecuación porque entonces esta igualdad
ya no se cumpliría estos términos eran
iguales antes de restar 12 y si queremos
que sigan siendo iguales estos dos lados
de la ecuación entonces tenemos que
restar 12 del lado derecho también vamos
a restar 12 de los dos lados de la
ecuación así que de este lado restamos
12 12 menos 12 se anulan y nos queda
solamente 4x y del otro lado tenemos 136
menos 12 es igual a 124 y ahora cuál es
el valor de x pues vamos a dividir los
dos lados entre 4 así que dividimos el
lado izquierda entre 4 y el lado derecho
entre 4 y obtenemos x del lado izquierdo
y de este lado tenemos 124 entre 4 100
dividido entre 4 es igual a 25
24 dividido entre 4 es igual a 6 así que
25 6 es igual a 31 de este lado tenemos
31 si les cuesta un poco de trabajo
hacer esta división en la mente pueden
hacerla de la manera tradicional
entonces tenemos 124 entre 4
el 4 no cabe en uno entonces tomamos el
12 y el 4 cabe en el 12 3 veces 3 por 4
es igual a 12 y restamos y ahora bajamos
el siguiente dígito que es 4
y 4 cabe una vez en 44 por uno es 4
restamos y el residuo es cero
x es igual a 31 y x es el más pequeño de
los cuatro enteros esta x de aquí es
igual a 31 x + 2 es igual a 33
x 4 es igual a 35 y x 6 es igual a 37
así que nuestros cuatro enteros impares
consecutivos son 31 33 35 y 37